Here we go.
There we go.
Now I'm a baby.
I'm a baby now chat.
White day elaborate.
I hate this.
Why are there so many singing ladies?
Please.
I'm fucking singing ladies.
What is up?
I'm only singing ladies.
How is it?
Okay, okay.
Okay.
Alright, alright, alright.
Is this supposed to be the- what the fuck is this
resolution?
I don't know.
What am I?
I don't even know what resolution am I supposed to be.
Okay, this is it.
Alright.
The baby.
Now I'm a baby.
Baby's not that scary.
Can't be scary.
okay all right okay all right all right it's not okay all
right new story can't hurt me i'm a baby i don't know i love
this game i've never met yeah yeah babies can't scare me
okay i need i can okay walk damn i'm a fucking i'm a smart
baby but seriously what the what the fuck is that What is...
What is that?
What?
Oh, am I in the womb?
Oh my god, am I gonna get birthed?
What?
I'm gonna get birthed.
Right?
Oh no.
Oh no, I'm just drinking water.
I'm just drinking water.
I don't know.
I was like, damn, that's cool.
I don't know I was like what the fuck is dude I just went
through a traumatic experience with layers of fear I don't
know shit right I was gonna be like oh shit this is a scary
game every scary game starts in the womb happy birthday
sweetie Wow, two years today.
Where the fuck would they get some fucking water?
I don't care.
I think I know a little someone is ready for some cake.
Yum, yum.
Chug-a-chug-a-chug-a-chug-a-chug-a-choo-choo.
Where is Dad in all of this?
Oh, fucking no.
Oh, there's Dad.
There he is.
Oh, she's sad.
I'll be...
Oh no.
Why is...
What are you doing?
Oh dad.
Oh.
Dad, get out!
Get out, dad!
Am I sad?
Hey.
I can count too.
I can't.
Look what I found.
Huh?
I wonder what it is.
Why don't we go upstairs?
Yeah, dad, where were you, huh?
Where were you when I was fucking drinking water and not
being in the womb?
Oh, my.
How much cake did you have?
Hmm, hmm, hmm, hmm, hmm.
Where's she taking me?
Oh, God, I don't want to look at her face.
What the fuck?
Oh, my God.
Oh my god I still keep doing medics on the table
Oh it's getting dark Okay there's monsters that chase me in
this game That's all I know And like you know what that's
fine Like fuck the psychological horror shit I'm done with
that I just chase I don't care Just like chase me monsters
Like I already have monsters chase me Then going through
that bullshit again
I'm a baby Oh, they just moved Look at all these boxes
Shit, what the fuck?
This baby has such a big room This room is bigger than,
like, my room
Or maybe it's because I'm tiny That's so it looks big
Okay, sweetie art like or maybe I'm just tiny it looks like
you hate or yes I absolutely got it please I don't want to
look at you yes I did you just see me rage quit a game after
20 30 minutes yes I fucking hate horror games I hate horror
games so much this is why it was a sub goal this is exactly
why this was a sub goal
space to climb okay all
right oh my god she's so oh my god what the fuck i need a
dude the sensitivity is actually crazy i don't dude what the
fuck is the sensitivity
oh my god you're learning up i just been wondering what the
hell is But you were scared of stairs.
Okay, here you go
Yeah, oh what what?
What the fuck?
Okay What the fuck are you inside?
Is there something inside?
Get out Do I jump on it?
do I do I do I do a jump motion wait was oh he was in the
toy chest I guess I thought he was in the pillow I I thought
he was in the pillow hello my name is Teddy nice to meet you
hey what's your name not much of a talker yet eh the pillows
are so jiggly let's play yeah i thought i thought the teddy
bear i thought the teddy bear was in the pillow that's why i
was like trying to i was like oh do i like fling it around
and then he's gonna come out baby come here turn around and
cover your eyes okay there you can look now
me to do i didn't listen i did i didn't listen to what he
said
wait what did he want me oh oh find the elephant i was like
what do you want me to do
oh here
okay so here super warm super warm oh here you are super
warm hey you found it is teddy cheap second at cheap as mom
i mean yeah he's like sewn in with patches and stuff and
everything does it work dude i can't have holy dude this
child has some spooky ass toys this kid's It has so much
shit.
Dude, what the fuck?
It has so many toys.
What do you want me to do?
Oh my gosh.
Animal, thank you so much for the follow-up.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
I do appreciate it.
Have a butthart.
Thank you so much.
Okay, I need to.
Give me a sec.
I need to turn up the volume of my game.
Because I had it turned up all the way to 7.
So I couldn't hear shit.
What do you want me to do?
Do you think the music?
The music box still works.
That's a nice melody.
What the fuck do you want me to do?
Is it gonna push me somewhere?
Oh,
I crawled faster.
What the fuck?
Oh my god.
Five thirsty animals upon a dry, dry hill.
Paying attention in the could use a drink they say it's okay
i have chat to pay attention for me i can just do this with
our newly dug well i think we'll have to bid each other
fairly well dude what the fuck he has more toys here why
does he need all these books for you're like fucking two
wait i don't know i don't know how old kids are supposed to
be and round hey pick me up and carry me on your back i want
to show you something we need someplace very dark he doesn't
need all these books how about your closet oh true true true
i know how old kids are supposed to be shut the doors
completely It has to be darker.
It has to be darker?
What the fuck is wrong with you?
What the fuck?
Warim?
Oh.
Wait.
Why did the song change?
Hope there are no more.
What?
Why did the music change?
How do I hug you?
a little bit safe Okay, F-O, okay I feel safe now I don't
feel safe I I don't feel safe What do you mean?
I don't think we're What do you mean?
I hate this I hate
Okay, okay.
Not supposed to be here.
Okay,
fuck you, bear.
Fuck you, daddy bear.
I think something's coming!
Oh, God!
Okay!
What?
What are you doing in the closet?
I don't think we're supposed to be here!
Stupid fucking bear!
How are you today?
You've got to stop hiding from mommy.
I hope you had a good birthday.
God, please, I don't want to look at you.
Can't trust the beer.
Apparently not, because he was like, we're not supposed to
be here.
God, please, I don't care.
Oh, my God.
Every little boy and girl are still here.
Rude has been lying about monsters and shit.
And they're waiting just for you.
We shouldn't keep them.
Dude, I already forgot his name.
I just know he's a piece of shit.
He's your favorite ever and I see...
God.
I hate those.
Please, I'm sick.
Stop putting...
Please stop putting ladies singing.
Please.
How long is this game chat?
How long is this game, guys?
Saying back to assert dominance?
Oh my god.
Preacher, thank you so much for the follow.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Have a butthart.
What the fuck?
Five hours long?
If you- Oh, so it'll just take me three hours.
Or two hours.
Am I moving?
Is my bed moving?
Oh, I hate it.
Q.
Why do I need to peek around corners?
How?
How do I peek?
It won't let me.
Why doesn't it let me peek around corners?
Why is the emphasis?
Oh, I must be stat.
Hey, look at that.
I did it.
I had to stat.
I'm baby.
I'm.
I'm baby What Please
Okay Okay I'm baby I'm baby I'm baby
Don't Don't you Don't you fuck with me Don't you fuck with
me Ram I'm Oh, why?
Why is this atmospheric sound so?
I hate this!
Why is the atmospheric sound so...
Why?
This is supposed to be psychological!
I'm looking.
Why is there another baby crying?
Why is there a little another baby crying?
Why did I wait till 2 a.m.
to play this game?
Okay.
to believe the adversary is getting to her.
Like, can you chill out?
Can you chill out?
Oh, dude.
Nintendo, shut the fuck up.
Ah!
I can't!
I'm baby!
Why is this so scary?
Okay, okay, okay, I got this.
I got this.
Oh, oh, okay!
Oh, oh!
The shadow!
I Love you Love you Love you
I got I got scared by my shadow I got scared by my shadow
Oh my god
Okay Why is Why is he crying why are you crying please stop
crying please okay okay all right all right give me a sec
guys oh wait is my teddy bear here wait how do i teddy bear
how do i teddy oh my god teddy teddy how do we get teddy out
how do Let me get you out, Teddy!
Oh, I plug you.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, I'm so smart.
Power.
Thank you.
Oh, God.
Something's...
not right.
Oh, sorry.
I'm not okay.
I'm freaking out here.
I'm just hiding behind this washer.
Alright, Teddy.
Are you stupid, dog?
Oh!
What the fuck?
Teddy, this is, his eyes scared me.
Oh my god.
His eyes actually scared me when he, when the eyes looked at
me and I looked back.
I freaked out.
I can't, I wish I could sleep, I gotta sleep.
I'll be brave and hang in there.
Noticity.
Okay, good night, noticity.
a good night there is nothing for you now I don't like that
wording for you now for now alright chat alright oh should I
plug you back in
okay apparently
okay Okay.
Okay.
Now run.
Ah!
Please.
Please, please keep crawling.
Please keep crawling.
Baby, your baby.
Your baby, why can't you crawl?
Why can't you crawl baby?
.
I'm safe.
Am I not supposed to be here?
Did I fuck up?
Wait, aren't you supposed- Oh, I need to find mom?
Dude, what the fuck?
Why did I need to find mom?
Just stay inside!
Okay.
Fine.
Oh no!
Mom can do whatever she wants!
I have to run back out!
No!
Okay.
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
Oh.
Baby.
Strong, baby!
Okay.
We're here for support.
Baby, strong.
I hate this.
I hate the sounds.
I hate all the sounds.
making okay yeah you know thing
okay strong baby strong baby okay strong baby strong baby
baby you're strong God oh God not like the stairs no no Not
stairs again.
Not stairs.
Oh.
Fucking shut up.
My gosh.
I'm freaking scared.
Whoa.
Oh, saving.
Why is it saving?
It's just saving.
It's...
Run?
Run where?
Up!
Oh, I hate this.
I hate this.
Down.
It's just...
Why is my heart beating so fast?
oh he's gonna strike baby oh my god baby run baby running
baby running baby running what what the fuck baby close baby
close baby baby baby why can't I close this why can't I
close this why can't I close you baby close I'm gonna hear
me Okay Okay Baby open
Baby Baby where Where baby Baby open Oh Open baby Okay No
more Okay Oh shit.
Dude, why the fuck are babies?
What the fuck am I doing up here?
Oh, did I go to the fridge?
What the fuck am I doing?
Big open, open?
I don't know what I'm doing.
I'm just climbing.
Maybe just climbing against me.
okay oh I get it oh no okay no no what the fuck does baby
supposed to do what is baby's oh chair chair oh I'm supposed
to get the chair what's
over there what are you Who are you?
Who are you?
That's your mom.
That's my mom.
Okay.
Okay, legit.
I gotta see it.
Okay.
Oh, oh, that was coat.
Oh, god.
It was, it was coat.
I hate this.
The man, I freaking, I hate this.
I hate this so much.
Fuck this coat.
chat oh my god
oh he was programs you to be free to code some big sense at
least okay okay I just need to close my eyes I'm run I have
to okay all right okay I'm running I'm running I'm running
I'm running baby run Baby, baby, no, baby, keep running,
baby, what?
Baby, no, baby, no, baby, baby, baby,
just keep crawling, baby, baby, just keep crawling, baby,
baby, please, just keep crawling, baby, baby, baby, just
keep crawling, baby, baby, baby, just keep crawling, baby,
baby, baby, where do I go?
Baby, where you go?
Okay, baby climb.
okay okay keep climbing baby keep climbing keep climbing I
got this baby you got this okay where where your baby go
where's it oh okay that was that wasn't a shoes shoes Why is
baby tired?
Oh, Frooter?
Baby, pull.
Oh!
Okay.
Ha-ha.
I'm a smart baby.
Baby smart.
Baby.
Close door.
I don't like this.
I hide.
okay I just need to calm down I just need to calm down okay
alright alright okay I hate this I hate this
baby go up where
are you at please
baby hide baby hide oh I'm hiding.
Is this hiding?
I hate this
Okay Okay, I just need to run.
I just need to run.
Oh Coat coat
Oh Please leave me leave me alone leave me alone leave me
alone, please leave me alone, please leave me alone, please
leave me alone Leave me alone!
Let me in!
I hate her, so she's still going to sleep, but it's her.
Hey!
Hello?
She can't hear us.
And she's seen me so distant.
Maybe it's more like...
A memory of her?
Wait, totally the monster represents anxiety with that help.
Oh shit, I'm so fucking anxious right now.
Okay, to view my memories.
Alright, what is this?
What are you?
The fuck?
Okay.
Down I go.
Baby, go down.
we go down.
Oh my god.
Oh my fucking god.
I hate it.
Okay.
This can't be scary anymore.
Yes.
Pick you up.
I pick you up.
Alright.
Now I can't be scared.
This is just a platformer now, right?
This is a scary...
It's not dark anymore.
I'm not scared.
Let's speedrun.
what's that doing here look see there's a house look at that
isn't that pretty dude this is like less scary than the
fucking my own house this is less scary than my than this
baby's house right
now is it locked i might be able to open it from the inside
yeah go in bet teddy man we just getting started oh my god i
think i just spent like an hour Playing a game, playing the
fucking first 10 minutes of a game.
I spend an hour playing 10 minutes of a game.
God fucking baby, dude.
God damn baby.
You put us here?
There it is again.
No.
It sounds like it's coming from behind this door.
There must be a way to open it.
It seems like...
these are connected somehow oh my god my heart my heart i oh
my god i don't know how i'm gonna do the last the last two
scary streams chat i'm i'm baby it requires some sort of key
really got into that bad that baby mentality
A baby
Okay Oh my god You know Bring me back to little nightmares I
rather fucking play little nightmares of this shit I This
first person shit This first person shit Is too much dude I
gotta be I chased my sister with long arms.
Buttons.
You're like, gaga goob.
I just let the story shut off that vlogging.
What happened?
Why didn't it open?
I was like, no, no.
There's no stream tomorrow.
Oh my god, there's definitely...
There's definitely no stream tomorrow.
Chat.
Alright, I'm fucking...
We have to press both at the same time.
Both at the same time?
Oh.
I was like, what do you mean?
Where's the button?
It seems like the- Yeah, layers of fear is gonna be a
fucking sub goal.
There is no fucking way I am playing- Layers of fear.
It might bring us to her.
It looks like we need three more.
No, I streamed yesterday, so it's just because I was for the
sub goal.
But holy- I am not streaming layers of fear unless- Unless
it's a sub goal.
There is, there's no fucking way in fucking play.
There's no way in fucking play.
Look at some fear after that.
Dude, no, not PT.
I've watched gameplay of PT, dude.
There's no way I'm playing PT.
There's no fucking way.
That lady.
Dude, that lady, dude.
I thought the other lady.
The other lady was scary, but that lady.
Oh my god, I don't want to go in.
Why did they why did the music stop?
I hate this.
I hate this music.
Okay, how many subs?
Oh Oh Oh
Ah!
Okay, why didn't you light that earlier?
Why didn't you light up earlier?
What did we learn?
But fucking baby!
That's the only thing I learned about this game!
Okay.
Okay, this is not scary.
I'm not at home.
Oh my god, I hate it when the baby makes sounds when he's
climbing.
I hate this.
Baby, please stop making Please don't.
I think I believe in you.
Adam, thank you so much for the five bits, Plana.
Thank you.
Oh, hey, what are you?
Oh, it looks a little creepy.
Hey, creepy.
Thank you.
We're the five bits.
Okay.
All right.
Oh, does it just...
Oh, it just keeps going.
Please stop making sounds.
okay baby run baby hide baby smile home thing okay i think
one i i don't think one of them is just the is the right is
right baby spin baby spin okay oh my god whoa over there it
looks like a memory oh memory is good memory is good memory
means Not scary.
Memory good.
Is there a way up this tower?
Okay.
Oh.
Memory good.
Puzzle.
Puzzle no scary.
Oh, thank God.
Thank God it's puzzle.
Oh.
Hey, Fanda.
Nothing scary about a player.
ground nothing scary about that oh my god why is there okay
okay where's just this okay i was gonna be like do i need to
hide do i need to hide or something oh oh oh oh oh i craw i
crawl i crawl i'm stuck i'm stuck oh oh fire bear bear bear
hug hug hug hug i'm sick
oh why is it dark
why are you dark
it's okay i hug i hug
oh oh it's saved i don't like that it's saved i don't like
that how do i get up how do i get up I that wasn't even my
phone that wasn't my phone how do I how do I get up oh I did
that's how I get up I don't like puzzles baby don't like
puzzles baby baby can't think right now
baby can't think please don't make baby think oh What do
I...
Please!
Oh, baby think!
Baby's thinking!
Please!
Wait.
What is that sound?
Oh!
Oh, I have to go in here.
Baby's stupid.
Baby's stupid right now.
My brain's still developing, guys.
Baby's brain is still developing
What the fuck
Okay Why are you scared Why are you scared baby Baby stop
being scared Stop this Stop this
Hold up, sorry, there's no wrinkle zone.
Anyone fine?
Oh.
I hope your mother is okay.
Who's this?
Oh.
Down.
Did I die?
Did I baby?
Oh, baby die!
I was like, down.
I thought we were supposed to go down.
I was like, yeah, down.
We were baby.
Okay, clearly it was not.
Okay, it was not down.
It wasn't down.
okay all right okay okay where the fuck do i go oh there's
another entrance oh what the fuck is i thought that was like
the fuck is around with this okay can baby die what get out
where am i
I hate this Oh, you should try I have never, dude No, no No,
I can barely Function right now As a baby I can't even
function as a baby Let it all over the yard
Baby Baby One more I have one more
Oh my god I have two more
What the fuck's wrong with you baby
Baby can't count chat Baby can't count I thought we I
thought we established that
Baby doesn't know how to count My brain cannot process that
What the fuck was that for Oh it's because it's 10 turn Okay
okay where's the owl
owl owl okay what the fuck where the fuck's the owl what the
fuck why did it make me climb please stop screaming please
please stop screaming I don't know what you want from me I
don't I'll scream back please just stop I'll scream back I'm
so is that it oh there it is oh there it is there you are
me smart
honestly stop
I'm running I'm running I'm running I'm running Please stop
falling
Please Please No, I need one more I keep forgetting that
need one more Where's the last one
Wait here?
Wait, is that it?
Ow, is that you?
Oh, no, that's just rocks.
That's just rocks.
That's just normal.
We're the fucks of the last
life, bud.
Thank you so much for the fall.
Thank you.
I'm a butter.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Alright.
I have this Where the fuck is the last one?
Where are you?
Up?
Up.
Okay.
Alright.
No fear.
Just actions.
Head empty.
I'm at least this one aim.
Can't sleep.
Zoyana, go to the fuck to sleep.
What the fuck?
Where are you watching me try and play a scary game?
You're not.
not going to be sleeping anytime soon watching this yes for
she be running I've been running so I've been running oh my
god no no
yeah because this is a stream is not going to get you to
sleep so yeah this is the stream oh ah All fear, all fear.
Panda, thank you so much for the five minutes.
All fear.
Oh my god, where is it?
Where is it?
There's so much fear.
There is so much fear in me.
There's...
Dude, I should probably sleep with two, but this is too
good.
It's fast.
Where the fuck is the last white?
Here?
Ah, what the fuck is wrong with this?
What are you?
Wow.
Ow.
Rock.
Get...
Rock, please.
Rock.
Okay,
why the fuck is a tire stronger than a baby?
That's so stupid.
Hey, baby run.
Baby run.
Baby, wait, baby no run.
Baby no run.
Baby run!
Baby running!
Baby's running!
Baby, baby, baby, baby, baby, baby, baby, baby, baby, baby,
baby, baby, okay, thank God.
Where's Tyre's driving?
Is he driving on the floor, baby?
Okay, all right.
Oh my god, wasn't even hard.
Wasn't even hard.
Baby's so fucking smart.
Okay.
the tire had certain potential gravitational energy so it
had the ability to move the rock okay why is my heart
beating baby please stop baby you should not be scared right
here you should have been scared a lot longer than the
okay I hate this I hate this I hate this baby i fucking i
hate babies i've never hated a baby more than my life now
i'm never okay okay we're memories it's memory zone we're in
memory town now oh thank god can't be scary now not scared
because it's memory time not scared because it's memories
Woo!
Not scared anymore!
Do you want to hear the melody?
I want to hear the melody!
Woo!
You just scared of eyes because you killed him from falling.
Wait, I don't want...
Memory!
Woo!
Can't be scared now!
Okay.
Oh god, please.
No.
Shit.
Is it still memory?
It's still memory.
Okay.
oh
finally we must be getting closer oh my god
oh i hate this so much oh shit thank god memory we made it
back okay pick you up pick you up enter the one oh memory
city can't be scared now oh shit yeah you're right find a
way to safety find a way out of this mess oh my god kevin
slap his lips time to get moving oh my god i need to hydrate
i need to hydrate after that holy but don't be afraid you
and me will work this all out together don't be afraid oh
god i fucking hate my day what the fuck don't Don't be
afraid.
This is like, this is like, just be better forehead.
Just don't get spooked forehead.
Stupid bear.
Oh my god.
Okay, I need one.
Okay, I got the second one now.
I need two more.
I need two more and then I'm done.
my guy how long is this game again how long is this game
again come on we have no time to lose
oh my god please bear can you do it for me
man this looks unbearable is the baby's portal here.
Look, he was like, yeah, dude, don't worry.
Oh, God.
Why is this so dark?
Why is this so dark bear?
I hate this.
I...
Oh, a
candle.
Give me the candle.
Oh, the candle.
Oh, shit.
I can do this.
Okay.
Okay, look.
Boop.
You're not thinking I'm safe.
Lear's a baby.
Look.
This is the only thing that's keeping me sane right now.
This is the...
Oh, do we...
Ah!
What the fuck is that?
Oh, that was just my reflection.
Okay.
that's why yeah okay okay let me let me give me a shot just
give me a second you shot let's just let me process this
real quick on you and you and you calm down
truly baby I'm truly baby guys okay so you got the rest of
the team covering the cow can't do nothing on you I hate
this I'm practically in layers of fear right now
I don't like this I don't I don't like this
wait wait what's up beer I fucking beer fuck I didn't think
about keeping quiet until now.
I didn't think about it.
Ah!
Okay.
This is my serious regret to inform you that we have lost
rain to the void.
They will not be coming back ever, so please send them your
love now before they go.
First and peace, my dear Bruton!
Okay.
Oh.
Why is there trees?
Why the fuck are there trees in here?
okay okay baby baby we're okay baby okay baby okay
why did it change okay now we're outside okay outside can't
hurt us okay I said that but then we were in the playground
last time Those floaty things, they look like memories.
Memories!
Memories can't hurt us!
Memories can't hurt us.
Let me out.
Let me... What the fuck?
Climb!
Memory!
I need my... Oh, oh, what the fuck is this?
What?
I thought I could climb this.
No.
No!
I want memory!
not puzzles I wanted memories not puzzles
oh no I need three puzzles okay oh my god why they're
paintings I fucking left layers of fear and they're giving
me paintings again why are they giving me paintings again I
fucking left paintings
paintings how do i fucking get up
do i crawl baby crawl baby baby no oh chair chair okay okay
i just need a yeah that's baby got this baby strong baby
please okay maybe not chair send those brain cells everyone
you got oh oh oh yeah yeah okay no okay that wasn't it that
was baby strong okay all right baby you got this okay maybe
that wasn't it maybe baby doesn't got this what the am I
supposed to do baby I'm still developing.
I don't know, shit.
Do you know I'm really stuck on?
You think baby's so smart?
Hey, that's right, you thought you got me?
I'm a smart baby.
Baby, okay, it might be blind, but I'm smart.
You're like, what's the real MVP there?
I hate this.
I fucking hate this.
Oh, oh, oh, dark!
I like a morning arcane, you know what?
Maybe Mario.
Pull?
Maybe pull?
Okay, maybe that's not it.
Okay, okay.
Oh, ah!
Water!
I can't water.
What is this game?
I don't want.
I'm baby.
That's what this game is about.
My little baby.
Hey baby, you got this baby.
Alright.
Alright, we're still.
Things are hanging out with us today.
I hope you I hope you enjoyed baby stream.
I hope.
Oh, he hate this
Hi, why why do people play horror games?
What the fuck is wrong with all of us?
What is wrong with us?
I don't even know how far we are.
Is this a sad boy?
What the fuck?
Oh my god, he's a sad boy stupid bee
I hate this.
Ah!
I think... I think she...
Am I halfway?
Push!
Baby push!
Oh, I don't fucking need you, Teddy.
What do I do with this?
Box.
Baby.
push what the fuck do I do with you box yeah okay how the
fuck am I able to push a box but not a rock earlier Jesus
Christ this is so inconsistent I can fucking push a box but
not a rock because rock made of rock but box is box yeah
what the stupid baby
baby drew out oh my god where did it take me where am i oh
maybe climbing in are we supposed to be really oh yes yeah
apparently babies are supposed to are really good swimmers
okay okay well my box is still there i'm just gonna jump why
the fuck did i even need a box i could have just fucking did
that what i didn't even need the box in the first place i
just ran and landed on here god this is so stupid
Okay.
Oh, pushbox.
Oh, large heroes even babies can play.
What the fuck?
Oh, God, actually.
Okay.
I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I touched him.
I'm sorry I touched him.
I'm so sorry.
Oh, my God.
I don't know if you guys heard that sound.
When I touched him, it made a spooky noise.
I don't know.
It made a spooky noise when I touched it.
Oh.
Open.
Oh, there you are.
How do I get out?
Let me out.
let me out of here let me let me out of here let me out of
here
my god i hate the sound he makes when he's climbing i i i
should like stop please oh
does he just save oh what is your we are not saving oh voice
for your layers of fear i it.
I fucking forbid the shit.
Okay.
I'll refund everyone if it fucking gets
a...
Baby, can you please be faster?
Baby, please.
I don't like this.
I don't like all this sound.
Baby.
Get in here.
Get in there.
Get in the fuck in there!
Fucking!
Oh my god.
Why did I take him 20 He has to get in.
Okay.
This place feels long.
Let's not dwell here.
God, bear, you're not helping me at all.
Bear, please.
Why aren't you helping me?
Why are you giving me negative reinforcements?
What the fuck?
My beard sucks.
You gotta get out there making me feel like shit.
Sucking.
Oh my god.
Why is, oh, what is wrong with this painting?
Look at it.
Why the fuck is her head going?
Monster time?
Wait, wait, what?
Wait, whoa, what the fuck, what the fuck did the painting
change?
what what i didn't even notice that oh my god
i don't i don't like this chat is he still safe
there there's no no no yeah that's just plenty of trouble
like 10 different horror games dude honestly honestly i'm
down for that oh my god is there actually monsters is there
is it actually monster time through this door through
through this painting is it actually monsters fucking
backseat this i I don't care anymore.
I need a no.
I need a no I I need a no Please I please I don't want to I
don't please chat
You go through this Oh my god
Vince Grimbell I Oh
I I feel like you should try playing some free indie games
or something They're a whole lot less scary and more funny
than anything Chat doesn't know I I fucking hate all of you
Okay I'm going in Ah Ah Ah Wait this is layers of fear This
is layers of fear You fucking This is layers of fear
I looked in it and stared back at me.
Layers of fear, but you're a baby.
Fucking not psychological horror, my fucking ass.
I don't know what you said.
Layers of fear have been lied to.
It never minds.
Layers of you just playing as yourself.
Yeah, baby.
Baby, is there a baby in layers of fear?
We didn't try layers of fear.
And then, and then, and this shit happened.
And then there's no more layers of fear anymore.
Layers of fear is a fucking sub goal now after what
happened.
I hate this.
Okay, I need someone that's not gonna fuck with me and tell
me, are there monsters in this?
I need a fucking no.
Right now, is there monsters in this, in this level?
in this particular level is there monsters I don't fucking
trust you Gamble you've just been there being like being
like hey is there scare notifications after you said that I
don't fucking trust you
of course not smile no smile
the fine monsters am I gonna die when a fucking thing
touches me in here like not am i gonna like not like i know
there's no fucking fall damage anymore because there's i'm
not inside water now but but are there monsters that's gonna
touch me and then i'm gonna die what if you just don't get
cups of mine i think the stranger shows the stranger shows
up here water is the truth i hate all of you I hate this.
I fucking hate this.
Why did I play a scary game at 1 in the morning?
Why did I do this to myself?
Okay.
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
All right.
Fuck.
I fucking baby.
I, I, I, I, I stood there for so long.
I forgot the baby makes a noise.
when you climb.
I've worked on my...
Okay.
Oh my god, baby.
I hate you.
The way I'm feeling this in spiritual novels.
Oh, why is this layers of fear?
I left layers of fear for baby.
I fucking hate you, baby.
you're fine for now for now for now
okay 10 minutes that's like 30 minutes okay that's good
that's like 30 minutes then
crawl baby my teddy bear I fucking hate my teddy bear he's
looking useless he's only here and be like you should be
quiet i think there's something wrong oh my
i didn't learn some fear yesterday i'd be screaming at
almost everything i could get past the fucking staircase you
me i i thought doors were your alley you know you're on your
doors in my garage
Oh, yeah, I screamed at this.
Ah!
I hate this.
I really hate this.
Shoe.
Fucking shoe!
Stop!
Stupid fucking kiddie.
Fuck this shoe.
Actually, fuck this shoe.
I hear my dad's dog barking outside for a second.
I thought she came inside, but it was you screaming at this.
Okay.
Alright.
Chair.
I'm sorry.
I'm sorry for pushing the chair.
I am so sorry.
Oh, okay, we're good.
That's good enough.
See, the bear led us here to our doom.
I've been enjoying the game.
I don't even know if enjoying is the right word right now.
I don't know if it's the right word.
Okay.
I crawl.
Everything is fine.
Get me up on this chair.
Ah!
I'm sorry!
I'm so sorry!
Please!
I am so sorry!
I'm so sorry!
Oh, I'm so sorry!
I'm so sorry.
Oh,
my beard didn't say shit.
The beard didn't say shit.
Stupid fucking beard.
Why does my beard say shit when the monster's here?
What do I do?
Please, please, please, please let me in.
Please, I'm baby.
I'm baby, let me in.
I don't know what to do.
I don't want to get up.
I don't want to, I don't want to fucking stand up there
anymore.
A baby, let me in, please.
I've been through so much.
I've been through so much, please let me in.
I don't know what to do.
Oh, what the fuck?
What the, it worked.
What the fuck?
I didn't actually let me in.
That crazy atmosphere.
It gave them so bad for me.
Fuck.
Look at that.
All you have to do is just cry in front of a door.
And it opens.
Oh my god, you're right.
Yeah, I trade after that.
Huh?
Okay.
Why crawl or stand up?
Oh.
I don't want to go anymore.
I'm sure I saw that monster.
I don't want to keep going.
Okay.
Why is this so dark?
Damn it.
It is so much with a gifted sum to Cessula.
Can we get some bark nights real quick for Gavit?
Forgiving us some To Cecil Oh my god My tracker's bucking up
Okay
Down Down Down
What is that sound Ah
Heart is it but but I'm sure follows I might be scared.
Oh God.
There it is
That's the he's the way you're the follow I'm a butter.
Thank you
Ah, I go I'm sorry.
I'm so sorry
Oh my god.
So when are you playing past Vant as well?
Okay.
If I see him.
Oh no.
It's so well.
Neville, pal.
He's under the rain.
Thank you.
I hope you have.
We had a good stream.
We were playing.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Ah!
That's okay.
I'm sorry she's having a mental breakdown.
Thank you so much.
I'll follow.
Done.
And Nick.
Thank you.
I'm a planner.
Thank you so much.
I didn't get to you.
I hope you have.
Oh god.
I am.
Not having a good looking time right now.
She's so cute.
Thank you.
Thank you for the follow.
Gaming and social.
How have we put arts?
Thank you.
Okay.
Alright.
I'm baby.
I am baby.
I am.
Oh, God.
What the fuck?
I hate this.
Thank you for the follow.
Do Carol, Carol, thank you, thank you, thank you.
I have so much, I have so much, my heart.
We read it to win us a day.
Okay, okay, okay, we got this.
I'm baby.
I'm, I'm baby, I'm out.
Oh, God, this is the well.
This is the freaky well.
Ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah.
Did I see?
Did I see someone?
What are your first impression of a do you have a crisis
crime pointing to die?
God, to go.
Oh, God, please.
Wait, down, down, down, down, down, down, okay, okay, look,
I thought down was the answer.
Thank you for the follow.
Ticey, Zoan, and Hollows.
Thank you.
Have some more.
Have some more fun.
You uh, you good at gate you're okay.
Okay.
Look.
I never said horror.
I never said horror was a game.
I'm good at
Okay Well, okay.
Okay.
I okay.
I need to figure out how to please let me crawl please
Please let me crawl down at least a mental breakdown this is
a crazy lady this is a crazy lady okay up up ah oh i turned
please catch why can't you pull faster why can't you pull
faster you stupid baby ah please Baby.
I'm done, I'm done.
Baby's done.
Let baby out.
Please let me out.
Why, why did this, why did this change?
Why, why did the music change?
Bear, bear, bear.
Thank you for the follow, Milky.
Thank you.
Where do I go?
It can't hurt me.
Does it get hurt me?
Where's the crazy lady?
Where is she?
God, where is she?
How do I get out of here?
Please, I just want to...
I just want to get out of here, please.
I hate this.
Please, please.
Let me out.
Please, just let me out.
Please.
Okay.
everything will be fine you're okay oh god you're okay
you're okay you're perfectly fine you are perfectly fine
your baby your baby oh my god i'm a perfect baby baby fine
were where does it want me to go oh oh
it was here all alive
look my brain's still developing i'm still oh my god i'm
fucking I'm so stupid.
This baby really funny is crazy accurate.
Okay, okay.
Let me up, let me up, let me up, let me up, let me up, let
me up, let baby up, let baby up, let baby out, let me out,
let me out, let baby out, let me out, let me out, let me
out, let baby out, let me out, let me out, let me out, let
me out, let me out, let me out, let me out, please, let me
out, climb.
Oh god.
Let me out.
Now run!
Ah!
What the fuck are you?
I'm ready!
Baby ready!
Baby, run!
Baby crawl.
Baby's crawling.
Baby crawl!
Where's the monster?
Where is she?
Who the fuck told me that there was no monsters?
Who was it?
Who said there were no monsters in this level?
In a specific level?
Oh my god.
Moonlight, Fox.
Thank you so much for the follow.
I love butter.
What is the monsters?
We're the friends we made along.
There are no monsters.
What the fuck do you mean?
What do you mean?
Okay.
Alright.
Fuck you.
Nintendo.
Okay.
As all you guys just forgot to check on the other Switch as
well.
Okay.
Baby.
I don't
know where they go.
Okay.
Calm me down.
Baby's calming down.
Okay.
Baby in barrel.
Bam.
Okay.
What the fuck was that sound?
Baby, just keep crawling, baby.
Just keep crawling, baby.
Just...
Nothing can hurt you.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Nothing can hurt you, baby.
Just ignore everything.
Just just like get get get get get get get get get get get
get get Please, wait, wait, wait, oh, God, please me.
Oh God.
I'm okay Oh my god, Jacob.
Thank you so much.
It was a fall Thank you Thank you for the fall Thank you I
Have a footer
No, I'm just very scared.
I'm just very, very, very fucking scared right now.
Why are they knocking?
Why is they're knocking?
I'm halfway.
I still have halfway left to the end of this puzzle.
I hate this.
I fucking hate this I hate this so much chat I chat I want
you to know I took my headphones off
my headphones are off right now I'm giving I don't want to
hear any more knockings I don't want to hear any
knockies baby weak baby's very weak right now okay oh oh
okay how do we get up oh god i fucking hate You guys, I
hate, I'm going back in my barrel.
I'm going back in my barrel.
Okay, I'm putting it back on.
I'm putting my headphones back on, chat.
You guys are making it worse when you're typing the fucking
sound sound.
I live in barrel.
This is my home.
This is my home now.
I have everything I need.
Ah!
Please stop knocking.
please stop knocking please please stop knocking the door
okay okay all right baby go up oh god baby please
okay okay i'll do baby go up baby strong we're barrel people
now i did i put my headphones back I put it back on.
Okay.
Oh, God.
That was my shadow.
That was like, fuck it.
Oh, fuck it.
Bear, bear, bear, bear, bear, bear, bear, bear, bear, bear,
bear, bear, bear, bear, bear, bear, bear, bear.
I love you bear.
I love you.
I love
you.
Sorry I'm so sorry I'm so sorry Oh my god
Am I safe?
Am I safe now?
I don't want to I don't want to go turn around I don't want
to I I don't want to turn around chat Okay Turn around They
have good really requires oh yeah Dwaratashi I'm so sad
right now I'm so sad.
I'm so fucking sad.
Oh, Kofi.
Thank you so much for the five bits.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Baby sad.
Can I come out now?
Can I turn around now?
I'm Beryl.
I'm Beryl baby now.
I live.
with the barrel okay all right okay i am strong baby i am
i'm strong berry
how do i get out how do i how do i get out how do i
okay that's strong and baby we don't need no i need my bear
i need my bear I don't I need my fucking bear guys okay fine
oh barrel barrel barrel barrel a barrel oh where do I go I
don't know where to go barrel is my only safe spawn right
now okay okay okay
Where do I go?
Where's the...
Where do I go after I get key?
I don't...
I don't know where to go after I get key.
I don't want to go out with the monster.
I hate this.
I fucking hate this.
Okay, okay.
Okay, right or left.
Do I...
Do I go this way?
Or do I go this way?
There's a lock gate?
there's a lock gate where the fuck's a lock gate I think I
deleted it the memory of the lock gate a baby lost baby is
so lost where the fuck's a lock gate
which way where's the gate I don't even remember there being
a gate when the fuck did I see a gate I just go right baby's
just gonna go right oh right is dead I want to take off my
headphones again till we get there okay when you try to run
away near the wall.
Where the fuck?
What wall?
I had two more walls?
What?
I don't remember shit.
I don't remember what walls.
Oh my god.
Just because I hate this.
I'm going back inside.
She can't get me here yet.
Oh my god.
I don't know what to do I don't
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay Okay, I hate this Me, I
hate this I, I hate this so much The wall was, there was
spider balls?
Is it gonna stay here for okay, okay, okay, I got this
Where?
Where's the wall where's the wall where's the wall where's
the wall where's the wall i
already did that yeah i already did that where's the wall do
we go right or forward i don't know forwards away but i
don't know where to go alex alex help me i'm so scared alex
baby must explore no please don't make baby Save me from the
street.
Okay.
Just go forward.
Forward leads to nowhere!
Ow!
Okay.
Wait, wait.
Oh no, that's the dead end.
You just...
Oh.
Okay.
Forward leads me to nowhere.
But I get bush.
Okay.
I'm 80 strafing.
I'm strafing.
Okay.
Where the fuck do I go?
Oh, uh, uh, push.
I'm okay, I'm safe.
Okay, chat.
Oh, barrel, barrel, barrel, barrel, barrel, barrel, barrel,
barrel, barrel, okay.
Man, barrel.
Oh, oh, ah!
I gotta call him IRL son.
I was just over here.
appearance we miss you Alex we miss you
am i going the right way guys please tell me i'm going the
right way because if i am not going the fucking right way
left left
left is ocean left is ocean
Where the fuck am I going?
Hole?
Can I go through hole?
No, I don't- I-
I don't know where.
I don't know where to go.
I- I peeped lost.
I don't know where.
baby don't know where baby just wants to stop okay am i
going the right way
oh where do we go chat please help me i don't want to
explore anymore i don't want to explore please Please, I
don't want to explore anymore.
The Stucky, take baby, put baby on back and carry me off.
Hydro Mom!
Why did you have to give it a name?
Why did you have to...
Why did you have to give her name?
That makes it worse.
Why did you have to give Hydro Mom a name?
I just wanted to call her the what the fuck please put baby
on back and tell where baby go I can't I don't want to
explore anymore fucking fucking backseat me so hard please
like what the what the fuck mom oh her name is lady of the
forest baby's gonna be in bush forever and someone does not
fucking take up the backseat gaming go for it and go right
and you can't see them they can't I don't think that's the
right logic I don't think follows I don't think that's
that's the right logic here.
Let's go right?
We've been here.
Baby's been here, though.
Baby, been right.
Oh!
Baby, baby, baby scared.
Baby scared.
What was that?
You can't see me if I'm in the bush.
You can't see me.
branch why the fuck can I carry a branch now what is this
branch gonna do what is this branch gonna do maybe have
weapon maybe have weapon okay all right any backseat gamers
in chat please please backseat please I just I just want to
get out of here I've been stuck here for so long.
I just so...
I don't want to keep...
I don't want to go the wrong way.
Oh, that's what made the noise.
That's so fucking stupid.
Oh, wretch gone.
Oh, no.
Wretch got it.
Okay.
Okay, okay.
My mind's gone.
Yeah, Lancer's right, my mind's gone too.
My mind's gone already.
What you play, what she's playing?
I hope she won't- I- You know, I don't even fucking- I can't
even trust Chad anymore.
I can't even fucking trust you guys, what you're saying?
But you're like, don't worry, the monster's gone already.
to worry about anything and then fucking you're like don't
worry guys there's no monster in this in this level you're
fine and now you guys are like don't worry the monster's
gone i don't think i could trust you guys anymore after that
okay need some oh god need more than just brain cells okay
i'm taking my shit fuck this i'm taking my headphones off
like this i'm about to deal this by myself.
I'm gonna fucking, I'm fucking, I'm taking my headphones
off.
Headphones off now.
Headphones off.
I'm about to explore this by myself.
Fucking taking my headphones off.
Oh my god.
Yeah, I won't even know if the monster's gonna come up.
I can't even hear shit!
Can't hear shit!
Can't hear hurt me!
Whoa!
Oh, there it is.
All I have to do is just take my headphones off what
monsters behind me do you think i give a look yeah i don't
care i can even stand
Oh my, look, I hate all of you.
Oh, don't worry.
The monster's gone.
You know what?
You can't fucking explore the forest.
I was like, yeah, I'm not scared.
I can stand on them, too.
Oh, my God.
I can't fucking believe it.
Oh my god, I fucking can't believe that
I was like, yeah, look at me, I'm gonna stand up too Oh my
god
Holy shit I hate all of you I hate okay okay all right well
now I know what the fuck's gonna happen after that okay is
there a way to avoid this monster where the fuck am I okay
do I just have to get the key or do the key thing really
fucking fast is that it is that all I have to do is that all
I'm not gonna put my headphones back on after that If I die,
I die, I guess.
Do I just have to, like, run super fast and then plug the
key in, and that's all?
Please, please, chat.
Is, yes, of course, we've been lost here for, like, 30
minutes.
We've been stuck in this fucking one level for 30 minutes.
Of course, this is the fucking first time.
Okay, so I just have to do the thing very fast, because I'm
not doing this, like, 20 times.
You guys are cooking, um, giving me, okay, which way,
though, I forgot, I forgot to get lost already.
Okay, okay, baby fast.
Baby fast.
Baby, baby, please.
Baby, please.
You gotta be faster than that, baby.
Please, baby.
Baby, please!
Baby!
Give this baby's time up.
Baby, baby, baby, baby.
Why can't I open this?
Baby!
Oh god.
Baby.
Baby, just keep running.
I don't know where to run.
Baby, just...
Baby.
Oh my god.
Just keep rooting.
Oh!
Baby up.
Baby.
Baby, stop, stop crawling.
Please, just stop crawling.
Just get up.
Just, just get- Please, just get the fuck out of me.
Okay, shh.
Got it.
What you did it?
baby did it baby did it baby sit down for a sec baby's just
gonna sit down for a sec chat i just i need to sit down for
a sec i i just sit down for a sec wait watch me baby
overcome some fears
oh my god I hate baby's just vibing right now okay okay time
to put the last puzzle piece oh god god I hate you so much
baby I fucking hate you so much
the last level the last one
is this last monster gonna chase me too is the last monster
is gonna chase me too
I need to know I Oh, does she?
The dress code in the beginning, probably.
To be fair, the man.
The reuse monster to chase you.
More like it's snuck off on you.
Oh, my God.
How the fuck...
I hate this.
Alright, how's this painting gonna change?
How are you gonna change?
Oh my god.
What the fuck is wrong with you?
Why do you not have a face?
Where the fuck's your face?
I don't...
I don't know if I can keep doing this, guys.
I...
I don't know if I...
I don't know if I can keep doing this.
I think...
chat I think yeah I think I'm gonna we're going to end
stream here I can I I can't
dude this last 20 minutes of hell 20 minutes of hell okay oh
my god we believe in you i don't believe in myself though
guys i i don't believe in myself chat
just take off
just remember to ugabugabugabugabug it's gonna help me here
3d okay okay okay i hate this
oh 20 minutes of help my kind of funny okay how about this
chat we'll finish we'll do another three hour stream for
this game next stream how about that guys is that better can
we double that i can't i'm looking into this fucking I'm
looking into this void right now I just can't this void this
void is fucking with me right now please please guys please
I don't think I can keep going I
I don't think I can go through There's a void right now,
chat.
Weird.
Let me.
Oh, dude.
Oh, God.
Oh, my God.
Stop whining.
Dude.
What the fuck?
You play this game yourself, Arizona?
What can you try and play this game?
If label, fuck you, Fable.
Come on.
Fable, how could you do this to me?
How could you?
How could you do this to me, Fable?
Also, time fucking Arizona out.
Dude, that actually fucking made me so mad.
Stop fucking whining.
Bitch.
Holy shit.
That is so fucking rude.
Oh my god, Fable.
Fable, how could you do this to me?
How could you fucking do this to me, Fable?
I love you.
But how could you do this to me?
Thank you so much for the five bits, Fluffy.
Thank you.
Okay.
Alright.
We're going in.
this is for fable this is for fable this is this is fable
drawer let me just sit in my chair for a bit no I'm wearing
my headphones right now let me sit on my chair for a bit I
need a I need a process this right now I need a fucking
process this?
Is this a maze?
Do you have to try to get out of the fucking maze?
What the fuck is this?
I have to get out of the maze!
Where the... Oh my god.
Oh my god.
Alright, so fucking pull me a fucking picture of the maze
right now and then you tell me where to go oh my god thank
you so much for the six gifts and subs thank you thank you
give me some work nights real quick for for nintendo for the
six gifts and subs thank you so much Okay.
Cute avatar.
Thank you.
Okay.
Alright.
I'm taking my headphones off.
Dude.
This is a fucking maze.
I can't.
If you want me to fucking solve a maze right now, I'm not
wearing my headphones for this shit.
Alright.
Time to solve a maze.
Oh my god.
God, Stupa.
Thank you for the raid.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
I'm going crazy right now.
I'm going crazy.
Thank you for the raid.
Oh, I'm getting spooked so hard.
My headphones are off.
My headphones are fucking off right now.
Because they made me fucking finish this last puzzle.
And I can't.
They put me in a maze.
I'm in the fucking maze right now I'm in a fucking maze.
I ain't wearing my headphones for this shit.
Okay Alright, let's go
Let's go
I don't know where to go Just kill me, just kill me, please
just kill me Just kill me
Thank you for the follow-up Thank you
No, I'm putting it Fucking...
Like...
Play on PC right now.
You guys are like...
Oh, don't worry.
It's amazing.
Fucking go...
And you're like...
Do-do-do-do.
Oh my god.
Like I said.
Fucking...
Don't worry.
It's just a co-man.
The sea monster girl.
The fucking...
What's her name?
Hydra mom's not gonna get you anymore.
She's gone.
Like, do-do-do-do into her.
I'm thinking Dude, dude, right binter Oh my god Okay, I
don't go straight What I've learned Is that I just don't go
straight Because someone fucking Fucking Paxi gave it for me
Okay Alright, so apparently I don't go straight apparently
yeah i'm at my daily i'll do that late i i need to process
this first oh my god which way do i go if i don't go
straight on his left okay i need to go left or then hide
your mom's in front of me okay all right
There she is!
Whoa!
Dude, dude, dude, dude, dude, dude, dude!
Oh my god.
Where am I going?
I can't hear anything!
I just let me through!
Oh, I'm not let me through!
Please let me through!
Oh!
People!
Oh, dude, dude, dude, dude, dude!
Dude, dude, dude!
Bed, bed, bed!
It can't kill me if I'm under bed!
Please just leave.
Thank you for the hundred beds, people.
How the fuck do I go?
okay i'm just gonna stay here for a bit guys okay i don't
know where to go after this i don't know where to go what
the fuck where the fuck do i go i have to go back out okay
let me i'm just gonna process i'm just gonna drink water
real quick guys I was going to sit in my water for a second
while I process what to do after.
We live here.
This is my home now.
Barrel is not my home anymore.
I've upgraded from barrels.
From the barrel home.
I've upgraded.
Okay.
Barrel baby's in bed, baby.
I'm bed baby now guys I'm bed baby no Oh god you're close
End it, end it Jericho, where do I go Jericho?
Fucking just tell me where to go Jericho, just tell me where
to go You know how to end this You know how to end this
Jericho Jericho Jericho
I don't want to go out.
I don't want to go.
This is drinking fucking...
Okay.
Just go there.
I'm gonna...
Let me breathe in.
Okay.
It's time.
It's time to do, to...
Oh my god.
I hate you guys.
I'm I you okay
okay okay okay
I'm going back I'm going back I'm going back because I don't
know where they go I'm going back because I don't know where
to go oh god please oh it's over here it's over here that's
that's it right over there right it's What is he doing?
I see it.
Baby,
go home.
Do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, do, next memory.
Next memory.
Fucking run.
Oh, god.
Oh, fuck you.
Oh, my god.
Oh crap, I cried and cried.
Cried so much.
I heard tears filled the bottom of the well.
That was me.
Give me that fucking book.
Give me that book.
Where the fuck am I?
Why is this sunny now?
Stop.
Oh god.
Let me in.
God, bring me back.
back home oh my god oh my god we're back get the in my hand
right now get in my hand oh baby he's back what was that
what was that thing dude shut the fuck up bear you did not
all he is there she seemed so sad and desperate all this
bear did was give me fucking depression what the fuck he'd
just never be like you go go you did it child good job no
he's just like man that lady was so sad oh my
god I know alright I'm gonna close
as you guys saw you play spooky stuff and never clicked at
the squirt link that oh Vic I'm so sorry we're about to we
just finished our last level today i yeah we're finishing
i'm not i'm not going through another level right now it's 4
a.m chat it's 4 a.m bear i'm not pushing that fucking button
dude all right we're gonna i'm just gonna sit down for a sec
guys okay no no we're gonna I'm finishing this game next
stream.
There is no fucking way I'm going to keep going Because
there's still the memory and and like A level after don't
fucking fuck with me.
I know there's a level after the memory You think I don't
know there's a level after the memory?
Don't fuck with me I might be baby, but I know there's a
level after the fucking memory I she's cheating you know how
I know because there's no way it's gonna end with you
getting other memories and being like congratulations you
got the memories and then bam boss level you think I don't
know that shit you think I don't fucking know that shit all
right guys I'm not gonna end right away I'll do the Q&A
session I'm gonna do the Q&A session so you know what I'm
just gonna fucking i'm i'm leaving i'm gonna be a bad chat